je reste à quai bonjour bonjour je suis
contente de vous voir
car en dehors du fait que je considère
que vous êtes
plus grands auteurs compositeurs de
chansons
vous brillez surtout dans la discrétion
ah bon vous êtes gentils la place de la
discrétion on appelle paraissent très
souvent et ce n'est pas tout à fait faux
ce n'est pas tout à fait vraiment plus
parce que je je pense que nous faisons
un travail passionnant et qu'il faut il
faut le faire toujours avec passion avec
plaisir des conjoints en étant très
heureux de le faire
vous avez écrit beaucoup de chansons
pour beaucoup de grands interprètes
je voudrais que d'une part nous incite
ya quelques années que vous parler de
ses expériences successives aussi
hamilton
le premier grand interprète que j'ai
connu c'était henri salvador la plus
grande c'est edith piaf et le la plus
récente rencontre avec un interprète
celle avec serge reggiani pour qui je
travaille beaucoup avec qui je m'entends
très très vite
les chansons que vous citez c'est une
façon qui domine les autres parce
qu'elle a une carrière inattendu et
internationales c'est mila et il ya les
autres chansons que je préfère mais qui
me diront rien qui diront peut-être rien
en public
les incas veux parler de salvador et une
chanson que j'aime beaucoup parce que on
l'a fait ensemble qu'elles nous tenait à
coeur qui s'appelle il n'y a plus de
membres une chose entrer chez moi il ya
une chanson que j'ai chanté écrite et
chantée avec barbara qui est la dame
brume qui est aussi une chanson qui a
une carrière moins fulgurante mais qui
est une c'est une complicité entre
barbara et moi qui qui m'a été très
agréable de chanter décret me voyez
surtout que l'un tempéraments opposés
aux n'y a qu' elle arrive à me donner le
goût de chanter par exemple la gamme le
communiqué des choses que je n'ai pas
toujours
naturellement je crois que je ne suis
pas un interprète que certains chanteurs
en tirer partie de mes chansons beaucoup
mieux que moi donc ya pas de raison que
je ne sais pas la priorité
vous n'avez pas vu l'émission avec serge
reggiani parce que l'équipe en france
mais si je redeviens mis à chanter une
très très belle chanson de lou qui
s'appelle madame nostalgie et il a
surtout à parler d'une chose qui est
très intéressant et a parlé de votre
manière de travailler avec lui c'est à
dire du fait que vous parlez surtout
d'autre chose que de chansons oui et que
quand quelque chose vous intéresse l'un
ou l'autre ou vous téléphoner je ne
revendique pas tout la paternité des
chansons que j'ai écrites pour gianni
parce que je ne laisse ni je leur laisse
une part c'est aussi quelqu'un de
stimulant sa chercheurs et puis c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être moi qui les
écrit sur le papier mais souvent elles
proviennent d'une conversation que nous
avons eue
et comme il est aussi inquiet que je
suis paresseux ils ne me relance
beaucoup pour savoir où j'en suis aussi
c'était comme ça qu'il fallait le dire
et il ne communique cette fièvre et
finalement les chansons se forme de ce
1er mai pour revenir à la phrase du
départ c'est vrai que que nos chansons
ne se font pas à partir d'un rendez-vous
comprend pour travailler je vais passer
quelques jours chez lui dans le midi où
il vient dîner dans mon île saint-louis
puis choses se font naturellement
voyez comme comme j'avais raison tout à
l'heure quand j'ai parlé d'eux
de discrétion vous avez une manière de
vous effacez derrière les autres et
peut-être même derrière vous même quand
vous appelez la discrétion de la paresse
c'est vrai que je vous parle des gens
que j'admire je ne peux connaît que les
placer devant moi surtout qui en plus
j'ai la chance ils se fassent
l'interprète de nouvelles chansons et je
vous ai vu par exemple chanter la dame
brune mais quand vont bien pour avoir
récemment l'enregistrement avec d'en bas
rhin et c'est très très joli et 7 en
même temps très amusant parce que vous
avez l'air d'être tout à fait dans le
coup et tout à fait absent elle est très
présent des leviers c'est vraiment la
femme qui vient vers vous et vous avez
l'air absolument hors dehors de la
question c'est tout intéressé pourra
louer la différence parce que il ya
effectivement une complicité une chaleur
qui existe entre barbare et moi lorsque
nous sommes en présence même temps elle
est d'un tempérament qui m'effraie et
qui me tout à fait étranger qui qui fait
que je me regroupe un peu sur moi même
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui vous
effraient kivu rêve qui vous fascine
tellement chazel c'est une sorte de je
veux pas pessah de l'incohérence parce
que le mot à l'herbe les sens mais
quelque chose
toujours en mouvement mais d'un
mouvement inattendu enfin on connaît le
premier on ne sait pas on connaît pas le
suivante une une vibration continuelle
alors c'est un tempérament très éloigné
du mien
c'est une femme cela je suis un
méditerranéen
l'accord se fait difficilement pu
s'écrier d'ailleurs quand vous dites oui
je pensais à ça je pensais slave savent
contre orientale et j'y pensais à propos
de vos chansons pour en revenir à vous
et je pensais à ce qu'elle marquait de
d'humour mais en même temps de
détachement et de certaines un certain
fatalisme d'une certaine sérénité aussi
c'est un héritage orientale
effectivement et c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être à ce propos là qu'on peut
parler de discrétion peut-être parce que
le français n'a pas toujours été ma
langue mais les mots sont des choses
très fortes qui m'effraie quelquefois à
leurs jours je joue avec eux quelquefois
je les contournent jamais de l'humour
quand je ne voudrais pas qu'ils éclatent
trop et les plus parfois ils sont plus
forts dans cette finale en tous les cas
de certaines certaines paroles de
chansons et collent tellement à vous que
vous êtes obligé les interpréter vos
mails ou des chansons que j'ai eu envie
d'enregistrer parce que j'avais envie de
dire les choses moment comme je les ai
pensé
même avec toutes les maladresses
je suis capable mais qu'il y ait
l'essentiel de ce que je voulais dire
sept voiliers que je très prétentieux
tout à coup mais il y a des il ya des
mots qui me concerne j'aimerais pas que
quelqu'un d'autre et je ne parle pas que
ce soit très prétentieux je crois quand
vous parliez je me disais une chose
c'est que après tout si vous ne
souhaitez pas tellement faire une
carrière d'interprète et si vous
souhaitez ça sort et vos batteries y est
comme les autres se battent ou 1,6 triés
pour être ici ce qui n'est pas le cas je
crois que vous auriez si vous faisiez
une carrière d'interprète vous auriez
trop peur d'y perdre finale entre
liberté septime merveilleux servitude
que de chanter tous les soirs une grande
exaltation mais que nous
je n'ai pas toujours prêts à payer le
prix est ce que ce n'est pas aussi une
manière de vouloir à tout prix rester
tout simplement et mais complètement un
homme
c'est difficile de savoir où sont ses
désirs où sont ses faiblesses je ne sais
pas c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire un
métier dans le monde du spectacle sans
désirer briller plus qu'on l'ouvré
mais effectivement ça ne sent pas la
chose la plus importante
je me souviens lorsque gt gt en amérique
avec edith piaf que j'accompagnais est
par exemple on ne pouvait pas se
promener dans la rue sans être connue
surtout après après un show de
télévision et un jour n'était c'était
infernal tous les gens n'arrêtaient tous
les gens m'a questionné le lendemain
vous allez en métro sauvé j'ai vraiment
une volupté de pouvoir faire ça et c'est
incompatible avec une idée de réussite
totale enfin c'est vrai
que j'aime bien cette place à moitié
moitié secrète qui est réservé aux gens
qui créent dans l'ombre pour d'autres
qui qu'il nommait qui vous met en
lumière des descentes ça vous accaparer
vraiment
et je souhaite vous que continuer à
vivre vraiment merci
c'est le souhait coup je fais aussi